all right so maybe by now you've played
and beaten Final Fantasy 7 remake maybe
you have it but I've seen more than a
few comments in the comment sections
people like um
the game is decades-old I'm pretty sure
we know everything by now so this is my
spoiler warning and if you haven't
played the game yet if you're like well
we already know where everything is
let's just let's act like I'm not
[ __ ] with you let's just trust you
know that thing goes both ways
so that's your fair warning if you
haven't played and beaten Final Fantasy
7 remake by now you're probably splits
um or otherwise you don't care you just
want to hear me ramble about things also
spoiler warning for the original Final
Fantasy 7 games been out for a while but
fair warning spoiler warnings done so
yeah at the end of this game a portal
opens up that go through it they fight
the arbiter of fate thus releasing them
from their fatalistic destinies and
Zacks alive now if you haven't played
the game by now and you're still
sticking around so you think you know
the story I warned you I told you trust
trust me in the [ __ ] movie so we're
gonna unpack all of that I'm gonna get
to it in a bit there are other smaller
little changes they made throughout this
game that I'm going to touch on first
which the meat of this is gonna be
talking about that ending in which I
should probably have Zack in the
thumbnail but I'm not going to because
I'm not a dick there are YouTube videos
out there to have him in the thumbnail
don't do that
why are you anyhow so I noticed the
changes we're starting earlier in fact
in the demo you know in the demo it's
like alright let's blow up the reactor
and then the bombs just kind of like and
that's it nothing happens really the
president Shinra actually pushes a
button and all the robots blow up the
reactor and so they blame it on
avalanche that's a huge change because
at the end of the PlayStation game that
they all start coming to grips with that
moral dilemma in their life maybe we
shouldn't have been okay with collateral
damage but we're better people now and
the old way wasn't the way and that kind
of absolves them of all of that but I
imagine we're not even gonna have that
moral dilemma we have when you start
dealing with alternate timelines just I
just feel like that's not gonna be a
conversation which is a bummer it was a
good character moment in the original
and then yeah these Harry Potter
Dementor looking shits come out of no I
was like what are they look white what
are they doing in this game I they were
not in the original wise I gotta make
[ __ ] up and for 99% of the game I was
like I hate them I hate these things
what are they why are they I don't know
why I have to deal with them and then by
the end I was like oh that's what
they're doing still why are
we'll get there but the other little
changes are when they drop the plates
you know the sector 7 events a huge
catastrophe in the world of Midgar at
least a city of Midgar and everyone dies
so everyone in avalanche
yeah Biggs wedge Jesse they all died and
but now wedge is alive and actually bigs
at the end do I just like the concept
everyone gets flattened and killed all
square squaresoft you got the balls to
do that [ __ ] good for you it's like
square enix it's like job we're not
going to though maybe squaresoft could
do that
we can't we're square enix we're
different the children it'll scar the
children we can't scare the children
that's why we took that whole trail of
ash and blood that you follow in Final
Fantasy's having the original it was
looking forward to that I was I liked
that scene to get out of the cells you
like what happened here suffer all it's
just massacred some folks there's a
trail of blood you follow the trail of
blood and it leads to president Shinra
and he's already dead sword through his
back Mazen moon just sticking through
his back it was amazing looks like whoo
Final Fantasy 7 you are violent you're
about as violent as night trap it was
good dog [ __ ] but again Square Enix is
like ah Squaresoft to do that not us
though or Square Enix think of the
children so now you follow a trail of
purple and black glowy Genova blood and
then you come up to president Shinra
who's still alive and has his whole I'm
a big bad guy and I have a gun to your
face monologue and then he gets stabbed
again I always liked the concept of you
think this guy is the bad guy oh look at
that we came up on bad guy 1/7 of the
way through the game and he's just dead
with a sword in his back this guy's
nothing that's the cool concept but they
were like well you got more time with
president Shinra i suppose he should
have a send-off but i just liked how
they did it in the original better so
yeah so i thought this thing was gonna
end like ok we do the motorcycle race
and maybe we go to the next town over we
go to calm and then cloud gives his
Nibelheim story and then it ends there
but then we got a little bit of
flashbacks with the Nibelheim thing so
it's like ok he's probably not gonna do
that so it's gonna end
after the freeway the motorcycle chase
we got the 30 minute motorcycle chase or
however long that is and then a portal
is there and then you
find out those Dementor [ __ ] are the
whispers of fates and they're trying to
keep everything in line you know it's
fate everything that's supposed to
happen everything that happened in Final
Fantasy seven the original is trying to
keep it in line with that because this
is portal to beat these things and now
they basically JJ Abrams Star Trek it
you're on another timeline in which new
things gonna happen yeah it's just I
have thoughts about all that also it
shows Zach but that was the moment I was
like okay so you need to play a Final
Fantasy seven because if you haven't
played seven and just run across this
guy here now in the end game and it's
just kind of this this blip this
flashback you're gonna be like who's
this dude out who is is he the guy in
the cover of that PSP game I haven't
played because it's not on the network I
mean come on
why is it not on the network also side
note if you haven't played Crisis Core
it's great it's awesome you should but
you need to get yourself the hard copy
of the game and a PSP and knock yourself
out have fun but I really liked it so
yeah so Zach steps on to the scene and
then you go beat fates and then after
the battle at the end of Crisis Core
there's gonna be spoilers in here for
Crisis Core but anyhow like after the
battle Zach's alive is who did I get
them all sexes alive and it doesn't walk
in with cloud into the sunset and I was
like good because they changed fates so
this is the moment I recently found out
it's not that cut and dry among the
interpretation of the scene I actually
learn that when my friend beat the game
because I mean we've all been there
right where you're the first one in a
group of friends to beat the game no one
else has you're just kind of waiting on
your hands you're like someone else
needs to beat this game so I could talk
to someone about and then one of my
friends text me he's like beat the game
I call him up we're like alright we're
gonna talk about this and we're talking
about it and I was like and yeah I do
now new timeline and Zach fair his life
crazy it was just long pause he did not
interpret it that way it says he was
like other honors I didn't see it that
way I didn't at all I was like how how
is that what so then I go to some of
those videos talking about it that shows
Zach in the thumbnail which they most
certainly and definitely should not do
right now but I digress
I mean we're talking about I just you're
gonna get less hits if you don't have
Zach in the thumbnail but you're gonna
keep the surprise open for some people
if you don't to moral dilemma point is
in the car I didn't even watch the
videos I went down the comments section
and holy [ __ ] yeah there are a lot of
people who are
Zach still dies it just doesn't show the
whole event and other people are like
nah zach is totally alive it anyway I am
live the mindset I'm in the boat of yes
acts alive now because you changed
history changed fate now is this kind of
this is why I think that in terms of
information breakdown how they roll out
the information here's just how I
process it okay first of all let's touch
on the fact that I like the voice acting
in crisis code more for Zach in this one
he just kind of sounds more cocky the
price of freedom is steep yeah the price
for freedom is steep we're gonna bring
the beer Leroy point is he's a guy who's
like oh I'm gonna beat some ass today
but in crisis core he's a guy who sounds
like he resigns himself to his fate boy
oh boy
the price of freedom is steep it's an
amazing moment
Zach's like I'm trying to get back to
Midgar to be with my girlfriend who is
Aaron thought he got ambushed and he's
like I'm gonna take as many of these
guys out as I can so cloud who's over
there hidden can live sorry Aerith not
making it home I wept a straight-up
cried in that sea of the PSP oh my god
that's why sac is so important to me is
because he was the hero that taught me
that heroes can be that amazing and that
interesting you know let's be real it
was a villain kind of guy Luke is great
Han Solo's better but Darth Vader's the
[ __ ] come on but along comes Zack fair
and I'm like dude you're better than all
of them he's he's so amazing usually
characters who are that good aren't that
interesting to me like of the Ninja
Turtles I'll take Rafael's the one with
more edge over Leonardo but Zack is just
he's better than all of them so anyhow
in terms of processing the information
or at least have square-enix gave us the
information in this game it's just this
is why I'm pretty sure Zacks alive so
you have a scene that's identical to
Crisis Core right down to the
cinematography Crisis Core the dialogues
the same as Crisis Core and this is
right when you're going in there to beat
these things that you already know if
you beat them then you defy fate and now
you can change history so now Zack gets
ambushed goes into battle
you beat the
arbiter of fate and then oh the next
scene is different from what the PSP
hides acts alive and he's like it's not
all of them hey cloud I won let's go and
then walking off into the sunset is zach
is alive crazy or there are some people
who are like no zach dies in the rain
and it's not raining yet and then it
starts to rain which means he's gonna
die later to me that's more of a leap
you know like the scenario was Zach gets
ambushed fights off as many as he can
but still gets gunned down now the
scenario is Zach gets ambushed fights
them all off lives the whispers of fate
get destroyed right in front of his eyes
thus indicating that history can be
changed while showing the cutscene after
his fight that's different than the
cutscene that was shown in crisis core
thus indicating that history has been
changed only to have him walk 10 feet
get ambushed by a second wave and then
get gunned down
I think the whispers a fake getting
destroyed in front of Zach and a
cutscene that's different from the
cutscene in crisis core is a stronger
indication that Zach lives and rain is
an indicator that he's gonna die in
about one minute yeah I think it's safe
to say that zach is alive again just
like it's safe to say if a guy buys a
girl a drink at a bar safe to say he's
interested in that way no it's possible
that he just wants a second opinion on
that mimosa just like it's possible that
zach still dies and we just didn't see
it yeah granted there is the question of
wool if zach is alive how does cloud
have the Buster Sword because you know
Zach died a soldier and then cloud
becomes a soldier cloud takes on the
buster story but I kind of see it as
Doc Brown the DeLorean and Back to the
Future 2 and Back to the Future Doc
Brown creates a time machine out of a
DeLorean The Adventures of Back to the
Future ensue then Biff goes back and
creates a second time line with the
DeLorean a shity her timeline in which
Doc Brown is committed but if Doc Brown
was committed that he couldn't have
built his time machine so how do they
have the time machine Doc Brown's time
machine still exists because Doc Brown
did make the time machine just in
another reality what they know is the
original timeline it was built by Becca
but now there's a reality where it
wasn't built by that guy so now there's
a reality where Zach lives and that
cloud does not get the Buster Sword even
though that cloud still did experience
Zach fairs death and Zach still gave him
the Buster Sword
so it's possible to live in the world
where cloud still has the Buster Sword
and Zach is still alive which I'm not
gonna lie to you that's an interesting
concept and again I've already gushed
about how much Zach it means to me and
how awesome me is the prospect of
playing as him in this remake
remake will fascinating concept more Zac
well that's neat but I also throw out
the hypothesis that maybe what makes Zac
as amazing as he is is his hero's death
in which what's the plan you know or
that are you gonna play as him are you
in this timeline is it some third
timeline you have like the Final Fantasy
7 timeline the remake timeline and
Zach's alive timeline is that gonna
cross over into your timeline or maybe
when you beat the arbiter of fate and
the portal sneezed you back out into
reality you're now in the reality that's
just like the one you were in but it's
the one where Zach's alive now even when
I'm saying it out loud I'm like yep just
like in my head it doesn't feel like
Final Fantasy 7 it doesn't it says Final
Fantasy 7 does have its mystic element
but it has to do with the lifestream in
the spiritual world versus the
industrial world industrial worlds
killing the spiritual world you know
that old chestnut when you start
bringing in things like fate and
space-time and other dimensions you
start crossing over into a story arc
that's it's more in line with the legacy
of kain story or BioShock Infinite I
could also see them bringing Zack into
it for the sake of well we don't want
Aerith to die now so now that the
variable exists of Zack being alive well
he can save Aerith now part of what
makes these characters great it's like
Zacks heroic and an aerith's
shocking death we didn't see that
happening but hey we're Square Enix now
not Squaresoft
think of the Chiltern but it doesn't
look like we're going to get the same
motivation like sephiroth's motivations
would bring the meteor down and then the
lifestream is gonna come to the wound
and Sephiroth it's gonna soak up all the
knowledge the Sephiroth seems to know
well that plan failed in another time
lines of gonna be different now I
suspect it'll be different now because
the game says it'll be different now but
in the world where we're on to a
different story path there's gonna be
constants and variables I imagine we're
still gonna get the gold saucer Cosmo
Canyon the story of Barrett and dine I
can't imagine it without those things
but we're definitely gonna get some
different stuff but I can only speak for
myself but at the prospect of a Final
Fantasy 7 remake I was just thinking oh
it's the story I already know but
updated graphics and we're gonna see it
in cinematic form I assume when people
were excited for a Final Fantasy 7
remake
that was their mindset - I don't think
anyone out there who was excited for
Final Fantasy 7 remake was excited at
the prospect and possibility that they
would open up a portal and change [ __ ]
but it's also we're thought that Square
Enix was like and the Final Fantasy 7
remake trailer just dropped fans are
really pumped it's like they're pumped
to experience the same story that they
already experienced on the PlayStation 1
only this time for PlayStation 4 [ __ ] no
we're gonna go a different direction
spacetime different [ __ ] it's
just a weird dot so I understand the
prospect and the intrigue that comes
from an unknown future for a story but
it's risk versus reward in a world where
people really weren't asking for that
when they bought this game - sometimes
when life gives you lemons you make
lemonade sometimes you buy lemons for
the sake of making lemonade and you get
apple juice I guess all the
advertisements all the signs says a
lemonade but hey [ __ ] it it's apple
juice now didn't you want that I thought
you wanted to apple juice [ __ ] hey we're
square enix not square soft
we make apple juice think of the
children so as to where they go with
this I mean we'll see was it necessary I
don't think it was just don't make Zack
some harbinger of doom or some old
grumpy guy on an island waiting to die
just we don't need that all right so the
Final Fantasy 7 remake and the end and
all of this what do you think about it
but ever you think comment below let me
know and as always a bit like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you